I came in this year wanting to get rid
of my imposter syndrome to work on
public speaking and to become the best
version of myself as both a leader as a
friend
the best experience this year was
getting to a low keynote speaker I got
to be part of a tribe of six other
students who have one transformative
idea server the course of 10 weeks we
brainstormed these ideas we workshop
them we practice them and we get used to
what it's like to hone in on one idea
one concept bring it to life with
imagery and ideas and adjectives and
then share that message in front of
hundreds of your fellow students and
then ultimately the world and this year
has taught me that it's more important
to show of us who I actually am and it's
okay to make mistakes and being able to
make jokes and connect with the audience
is actually more important than being
perfect I've learned what are the things
that make me a unique leader that make
me someone that others would want to
follow and why I'm a leader that is
going to make a difference in the world
instead of drawing confidence from the
things that I've done that confidence
now comes from a deeper understanding of
myself and the values that I bring
there's nothing that can really describe
how transformative this year has been
it's been a once-in-a-lifetime
experience
you